an ideal state consists of three main  classes of people  rulers warriors and craftsmen the rulers  are philosophers who can reason and  think deeply and provide a good ruling  system for the city the warriors guard  the city from internal and external  threats the craftsmen are mainly  producers and provide the city with the  necessary products and services required  to run properly the reason plato decides  to use these three categories is because  he believes that people have three  fundamental behavioral tendencies  appetite spirit and reason and that in  every person one of the three tends to  prevail the ones who gravitate towards  appetite should become craftsmen the  ones in whom the spirit prevails should  become warriors and the ones who hold  the reason as the ultimate virtue in  life should become rulers a society is  just when relations between these three  classes are balanced